agents the next Target to be rescued is
vicr mik he isn't necessarily one of our
favorite people and even has a history
of screwing us over but he is a member
of our community and will be responsible
for stabilizing power in the settlement
just in time for winter agents get him
[Music]
back
before the green poison outbreak vram
mik better known as Vic or Vic the dick
was the CEO of odia electronics once an
ally turned Black Tusk puppet and then
once again an ally he isn't exactly
someone who can be trusted But like
everyone else he brings his own
expertise and experience that elevates
the people around him especially in
relation to energy infrastructure Vic
always thinks he's the smartest person
in the room even though this is really
true however he does have some very
strong Connections in the military
industrial complex including Ortiz
robotics Kelvin McManus and Natalia
Sova stop keep your hands where I can
see them don't shoot I'm unarmed State
your business I need assistance and
lodging I haven't eaten in days look
I've never seen you before I can't just
let you in can anyone vet you Manny
Ortega wait there this is Manny hey
Manny sorry to bother you got a stranger
here says you can bet him what's his
name what's your name fcam Malik fcam
Malik take him into custody I'll be
there as soon as I can keep your hands
where I can see them oh good guess I
left an impression I'm unarmed I'm not a
threat we'll see about
that this was sometime after vicr had
betrayed us the first time and left us
to be ambushed by the hyenas it would
appear that he hadn't quite managed to
get what he needed in order to survive
in this new world and would come
crawling back to Society of course vicam
isn't really a name you can forget so
many ordered his immediate
arrest what happened Vic H you know same
old story fell in with a bad crowd
friends used peer pressure you make some
bad choices and end up regretting that
decision and hope it's not too late to
change you led my agents into a trap uh
technically I didn't know it was a trap
until I had to spring it I can't trust
you Malik I'm not asking you to trust me
I'm asking you to align with me against
the mutual enemy Natalia Sova her too if
you're talking about schaer this
conversation is over I'm talking about
cow what do you know about McManus how
do you think I met Natalia you know how
they say there are six degrees of
separation to anyone in the world sure
well for Rich [__] in
DC there is three and if you have
defense contracts it's one Calvin
mcmanis you give me Intel on mcmanis and
Sova
and we protect you from the hunters and
Black
Tusk that's your offer you also get my
charming personality Superior intellect
and access to odia Tech I'm sure you
could use some Power Solutions as we
move into winter let's see what Intel
you have before you start making
promises you can't keep hey you got the
batteries I never lied to you about the
batteries I just didn't tell you about
the system
wipe while being interrogated by Vic
would go on to tell him about the fact
that he'd been working with a bad crowd
and almost immediately regretted it so
once he was able he escaped and made his
way towards a jtf controlled settlement
it would turn out that he had been
working for Natalia since all the way
back then but also Kelvin mcmanis given
the obviously valuable Intel he has
Manny makes him a deal in return for his
safety system Purge complete I did what
you asked I purged all records of your
involvement with odia do we have a deal
or not just two more things and then I
know I can trust you Vic fine trigger
the alarms and read your lines Nat I I
can't read that I'll sound like an
[__] if you want my help you'll find
a way God damn
it fine oh and do your best to sound
sincere I'll try I know that's hard for
you oops I seem to have tripped the
alarm every hyena inside two blocks is
probably on their way here to
investigate this is actually back when
Vic was in the process of screwing us
over quite some time ago now the whole
reason he was wiping the systems was to
hide Natalia's involvement with Oda like
always Natalia was pulling the strings
and ordering him to do everything on the
fly it was her who forced him to trigger
the alarm and even forced him to say
what he said I wouldn't go as far as to
say that he isn't an [__] he's maybe
just not quite as big big and [__] as
we thought he was kind
of Cal great to see you again Vic what
have you got for me today solar powered
relay stations for all your offsite
tactical power needs this your idea or
birdy's birdy's brain my money so you
get all the
credit love it you want to place an
order you've got competition on my
production line if you want to get this
out to your troops to test next spring
I'll let Talia take the A&D hit she can
afford it what I really need are
autonomous power sources that can either
be self- sustaining using solar wind
Hydro or geothermal whichever is more
appropriate for the region that needs
little to no maintenance and is
basically idiot proof and if it can
power climate control an automated
defense system and a CNC machine at the
same time even
better yeah that's too specific to be a
random request Cal oh it's not random
but it's classified so do you have
something that can work or do we need to
take birdie into this conversation I
could hack something together but what
you're talking about needs to be sight
specific and that's going to require
bird's brain for a modular sight
specific generator or custom builds for
each classified location so if you want
to keep it modular we need
birdie this is the first time we hear of
Birdie Vic's sister she is someone it
sounds like we really need on her side
it's own like clar Ortiz an absolute
technical genius so where is she
now agents receed Intel that Vic could
be being held at the new Venus control
point in the westan district of DC the
control point is completely full of the
Suns out guns out true Sun soldiers but
before signaling for jtf support the
agents greet the Defenders using the
festive weapon of choice the O Carol
countering the jtf attack the true suns
were never able to regain control of the
complex and will find themselves
succumbing to The Marksman fire in a
hail of confi and
fireworks upon eliminating The Last
Enemy agent Johnson alerted the agents
to a confirmed sighting of Vic in the
historic
District him you're
going sting of Vic in the historic
district we could have done that without
you made it
[Music]
through agents were able to track down a
high value Target known as Alona
chipmunk Dakota the black task officer
had locked down this neighborhood with a
large contingent of true Suns fighting
through between and on top of the
buildings they would eventually meet up
with chipmunk
rather than going down and meeting them
on the street the agents decided to keep
spreading the Christmas cheer from
above the target
agent once eliminated a hostile cons was
[Music]
intercepted hostile radio
intercepted why did you bring me here
that you said you needed more fuel for
your batteries I do but no one has
delivered gas to the Riverside Station
in almost a year whatever is here is
worthless it would be discovered that
Vic was last seen at the Riverside
Station the agents pack up the gear and
quickly make their way to the
site the agents once again called in for
support from the jtf taken by surprise
the true Suns on site rushed out onto
the street firing wildly in the
direction of the agents after taking out
the leader they were were able to secure
a defensive position above the building
from there they were able to comfortably
repel the Hostile Counterattack once the
facility was secured agent Johnson could
once again be heard over the comms they
not in
cover hostile
broadcasted got reports of Vic at the
garage we should check it out or not I
mean does anyone really give a [__]
about
Vic heading down to the Southeastern
side of the
the agents would follow another lead
wasting no time they ambushed the
defending soldiers on the street
entering below through the underground
car park they were greeted by another
small group of true Sons but it didn't
take long to remove them in fact their
mates in the Next Room didn't even hear
all the fighting and were also caught by
surprise after clearing a few waves of
support the enemy leader would enter the
fight his entire bodyguard unit would be
nice enough to line up and quickly drop
to the agent for must spam facing the
agents one-onone the high value Target
proved that he had obviously come into
his position purely because of lack of
options from his superiors as his
offense could really only be described
as sad and a little bit
[Music]
pathetic
agent Scout spotted Vic with the
recruiter at the bank so we're good then
recruiter has Vic and we get to take a
well-deserved nap I mean do we really
need
Vic Target down good
job Vic mik's last known location was at
the bank
headquarters rumor is Vic has a safety
deposit box the bank and soov wants
whatever's inside it I can't believe
we're risking your life for Vic
Malik the true Suns had a huge force on
site agents would have to hunker down
and slowly pick them off one by
one
once cleared they would move on to the
next section and greet them with a
series of festive bursts but this was
just a distraction and the Agents soon
found themselves being
flanked
but this was brought under control and
they would quickly eliminate the
Defenders including a Black Tusk officer
and continue moving through the facility
towards the final
Target
guess right
now climbing to the upper levels agents
would be surprised to find hostiles that
were oblivious to the attack playing out
eventually they would find themselves in
a room that they had once rescued a
former president Ellis from the true
Sons had chosen this to be the place of
they Last Stand I'm going to waste every
last one of
you just slide
down got big agent meet me at the castle
then go get my sister
birdie so
I heard a rumor Gat did medical
experiments on your pregnant
girlfriend installed a mobile shade
server killer in her uterus and now
everything is [__] I don't have time
for your [__] Vic it's not [__]
Nat took us all for a reason she's
recruiting she's looking to expand her
Empire and what greater get than the
pregnant girlfriend of the last
honorable man in DC Mr accidental pus
himself
Manny Orga that's not funny Vic come on
Manny you got to lighten up your
therapist will be very disappointed with
you when was your last session I don't
have time for this I need to find birdie
and figure out what's actually wrong
with the server and no I do not believe
that Natalia Sova replaced our baby with
a device that can remotely kill a mobile
shade
server like I said before Vic is an
[__] and this is well documented
there with his debrief with Manny after
his rescue replacing an unborn baby with
a mobile shd server destroying device
good God Lauren I'm not going to lie I
actually like Vic a little more after
this rescue yes he's still a dick just a
little less Sinister than he seemed once
before he's just a quirky jerk who is
definitely more out there for himself
than anyone else like every fourth
Target I've kept this one short and
sweet as the final Target is now
available so I want to get on to that
one sap so without further Ado I'll
close this one off and get working on
the recruiter thank you for watching and
extremist mice extrema
[Music]
[Applause]
remedia